hi everyone in this video have talk
about natural killer cells or NK cells
now as the name suggests they're kind of
talked much cleaner and indeed natural
killer cells are the lethal weapon of
our immune system so we can compare
natural killer cell to a highly
qualified SpecOps who can kill anyone in
its way and natural killers are loaded
and ready to kill any of the cell that
they would see once activated so now
let's look at where does natural killer
cell come from where are they born so
natural killer cell comes from
hematopoietic unipotent stem cell so
from hematopoietic to reportin stem cell
it give rise to a lymphoid progenitor
and from lymphoid progenitor the t-cell
and b-cell these things also develop and
also from the same progenitor the NK
cells develop but the details of NK cell
development and their differentiation is
not yet understood now here is NK cell
as you can see there are lot of
receptors on their surface so NK cell
has a set of activate receptor and a set
of inhibitory receptor which plays very
important role
so these functional roles we would
discuss in subsequent slides before that
let me tell you that NK cells are highly
loaded with cytotoxic granules
containing perforin and granzymes
also NK cell has its lineage marker in a
1.1 on its surface apart from that in
key cell expresses FC receptor FC
receptors are receptors for FC region of
antibodies and also it has fast ligand
fast ligands are important for fast
ligand fast receptor mediated cell death
now
among the activator II and the
inactivated receptor one of the most
important activated receptor is nkg 2d
which can interact with HLA e and also
bind to Mick a Mick P and he will be be
family members and one of the important
inactivate remember is ki r and ly 49 so
we would soon we would understand about
their function why the india cells has a
set of active a tree and a set of
inhibitory receptors now first question
that we should ask is how the incas cell
knows that a host cell is infected by a
virus i forget to tell you that NK cell
is very important against for the
immunity against virus infection and
also against tumor so first question
that comes in our mind is that how NK
cell understand that of cell is infected
by the virus before knowing that let's
just understand that what happens when
the cell is infected by a virus here the
same in yellow is infected by the virus
and also the virus get inside its
genetic material shown in red is getting
transcribed and translated and it is
forming viral protein now cell has its
own machinery to degrade proteins some
of the viral proteins are also degraded
by proteasome mediated degradation and
the degraded proteins get inside the
endoplasmic reticulum for a tap
transporter and loaded on to class one
MHC molecules and also these viral
peptides along with some self peptides
are displayed on the surface of this
infected cell now there are surveillance
candidates who are searching for queues
of viral and once it's candidate is our
cd8 positive cytotoxic killer T cell so
cd8 positive T cells can recognize the
MHC class 1 bound viral peptide and can
actually kill the cell now virus has
over time evolved and they have taken
different strategy to hide from this cd8
positive T cell you know in order to
hide from cd8 positive T cell they down
regulate a when C class 1 molecule
displayed on the surface so a CD 8
positive T cell would be confused and
would be thinking that everything is
fine and everything is under control but
the virus doesn't know there is another
silent killer sitting who is our NK cell
NK cell thinks there is something wrong
but how does NK cell knows that in case
I'll engage with MHC class 1 molecule
now MHC class 1 molecule and NK cells
inhibitory receptor give rise to a
signaling which tells the NK cell that
everything is okay with the cell that he
is scanning now interaction with a
inhibitory receptor and the MHC class 1
MHC class 1 molecule gives a negative
signal which tells the NK cell to
disengage but think about a time if a
virus infected cell try to hides itself
from cytotoxic T cell it would down
regulate the MHC class 1 molecule and it
has been seen for many viral diseases
many normal cell down regulate their MHC
class 1 expression on the surface so in
that situation NK cell would clearly
understand that there is something wrong
and the negative signal provided is not
there so nothing is telling that NK cell
to disengage so it is ready and you can
engage and kill the cell now since the
NK cell has already known that there is
no there is no class 1 MHC bound peptide
and there is something weird happening
to the cell it would killed us but now
we would ask what is the killing
mechanism so NK cell has an
a lot of secretory granules containing
perforin and granzymes which can
ultimately give rise to apoptosis of the
target cell
now NK cell secretes for for a hand
granzymes this part foreign and
granzymes are internalized inside the
cell and the granzymes make a pouring
the vesicle from which the peripherals
can come out and the porphyrins interact
with big protein on the mitochondria now
that this bit protein and buffering make
a lot of pores in the mitochondrial
membrane and ultimately this results in
cytochrome c leakage now cytochrome c
should not be present in the cytosol one
cytochrome c is present in the cytosol
it can interact with above one an a p--
of one can do one of the bad things
Hiep of one can cleave a pro caspase-3
or an inactive version of caspase-3 two
cleaved caspase
so once cleaved caspase-3 is activated
it can lead the cell to a program
destruction program which is known as
apoptosis
apart from these perforin and granzymes
mediated killing NK cell can also use
fast and fast ligand mediated signaling
fast and fast ligand mediated signaling
converts active inactive Pro caspase-8
to a cleaved an active form of caspase-8
now these cleaved caspase-8 can also
lead to further cleavage of inactive
caspase-8 and ultimately forms a cleaved
an active version of caspases field
remember caspase-3 is the executor gas
phase which would do multiple downstream
damage breaking down the cytoskeleton
cleaving the DNA materials activating
multiple other proteases etc and thereby
the cell is destroyed and the target is
destroyed now here is the two receptor
model for NK cell how they work
castle has a set of activator II and
inhibitory receptor the target cell also
have activated receptor activity League
and for NK cell so always there is a
signal that is telling the NK cell to
engage and give it that's why they are
like spec ops they don't care about
anything and they kill everyone in their
way okay now NK cell would not engage if
it has a inhibitory signal if the skill
is in a proper condition not virally
infected so it would normally Express
class 1 MHC and it would display the
self antigens on class 1 MHC now
individual receptor of NK cell would
recognize that and send a negative
signal to the NK cell this negative
signal and the positive signal balance
each other and ultimately in case L
would disengage and do not keep the duck
itself but think about a situation when
the cell is infected by the virus and
there is no MHC class 1 expression so
there is a constant activity wife took
for engaging but there is nothing to
tell the NK cell to disengage in this
situation NK cell would engage and kill
the virus infected cell now how does
scientists know that in case I'll use
this kind of MHC 1 based recognition
mechanism what scientists did is they
took a cell culture in there they
infected the cells with its empower
virus epstein-barr virus does what is
down regulate it's well known to down
regulate MHC class 1 month and then they
add NK cells into that culture as a
result what they saw is there is a lot
of apoptosis and will not have cell
death in the culture that suggests that
MHC 1 based a recognition is important
for NK cell they did another set of
experiment when they definitely took
infected the cells with epstein-barr
virus and as expected the cell has down
regulated its MHC class 1 but they also
artificially restored the extra
of MHC class 1 by using transfecting by
translating expression vectors now the
cells even they are virus infected they
are artificially induced to Express MHC
class 1 and after that NK cells are
added to the culture and what they saw
is something stunning but almost no
apoptosis even if the cells are infected
by the virus so that leads to the
understanding that a make that MHC class
1 based recognition is used by NK cell
to engage and kill its target cell and
also tumour cells are destroyed by NK
cells NK cells has multiple different
activity and inhibitory receptors that I
have listed here in green they are
active a tree in red they are inhibitory
and therefore NK cells play a very
important role against tumor now as per
summary what we have learned is encases
originates from lymphoid progenitor just
like t-cell and b-cell NK cell plays an
important role against tumor and viral
infection also in kissing expresses its
bonafide marker NK 1.1 and also contains
several cytotoxic granules as if they
are always ready with the nuke for
killing its enemy NK cell has a set of
activator E and inhibitory receptors and
we also looked at how they work NK cells
scan for MHC 1 molecule on the surface
and engage in killing if the cell do not
express MHC 1 so these are the few
important features of NK cells now if
you liked my video give it a quick comes
up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you